The Octavia is one of Skoda's most successful
vehicle ranges
and includes the sporty RS models.
Recently the Octavia underwent a facelift
and we're going to test its mettle.
Our tester Michelle Assenmacher says she's
going to test the Octavia RS
at a driver safety training center.
And she knows it'll be fun!
That's largely thanks to the car's turbo diesel
engine, which churns out 135 kilowatts of power.
It propels the new Octavia RS to a top speed
of 230 kilometers an hour, and lets it to
go from 0 to 100 kilometers an hour in
7.9 seconds.
Our test model sells for around 33-and-a-half
thousand euros in Germany.
The slalom course isn't the only part of the
test site that's under water.
In a flooded roundabout, Michelle tries to
get the Skoda Octavia RS to stay on track.
That's harder than
it looks....
"Okay, I give up", she says -- and leaves
this part to the professionals....
This is what it looks like with a trained
pro behind the wheel!
But Michelle says she's game to tackle this
slalom course.....
The Octavia's RS models -- badged as vRS in
some markets -- have a 15 millimeter lower
sport suspension.
Other features that add to their sportiness
include progressive steering and optional
Dynamic Chassis Control which lets drivers
choose between Sport, Normal and Comfort modes.
Inside, Michelle shows us one of Skoda's 'Simply
Clever' solutions that can be found in the Octavia RS.
She can open this water bottle with just one
hand, drink from it
and close it again, while
keeping one hand on the steering wheel.
The new front looks masculine and sporty.
Full-LED headlights, set on either side of
the radiator grille, make the car appear wider.
The hood and the sharper lines at the sides
give the car an 'edgier' look.
At the back, the rear spoiler adds a sporty
accent.
The abbreviation 'RS' stands for 'racing sport'.
RS variants made their way into the Skoda
range in the year 2000.
Since then these sporty models have won over
more and more fans.
Skoda's Octavia RS has proved particularly
popular.
Michelle says she likes taking tight curves
with it best.
The car whines and roars....and it's just....Wow!
It's a driving experience that you simply
have to experience for yourself.
It's incredible, because the car is so
good on curves.
And that literally leaves Michelle speechless!
All in all, the RS's facelift has done more
than just spruce up its outer appearance.
Changes have been made inside as well.
The result is a sporty sedan, which has certainly
put a smile on our tester's face.
Michelle says she's had lots of fun today.
She could leave the traffic behind and push
the Octavia RS to its limits.
Though she admits it was more HER limits that
were being tested, because in the hands of
the pros the car can definitely do more.
She thinks the Octavia RS is a good mix.
It's fun, as she found out today, and good
for everyday use
thanks to its 'Simply Clever' solutions.